the jurogan experience you came on my
radar
when uh you were discussing uh um
that's the right thing which is an
object that we detected in space
that you believe could possibly have
been extraterrestrial
in origin meaning from some sort of a
civilization
right yeah why did you did what please
explain to people what a muammuala is
why it's so extraordinary and why you
think it's possible that it came
from some other intelligent civilization
right so i'm a scientist
and i basically follow the evidence just
like sherlock holmes
trying to find solutions it's a
detective story you have
some anomalies some things that don't
quite match what you expected
and you're trying to find an explanation
and
the thing about omua moa is that it was
discovered on
october 19 2017. a little more than
three years ago and it was the very
first
object that visited our vicinity in the
solar system
from outside the solar system it moved
too fast to be bound to the sun
very first object that we have found
coming to us from interstellar space
from other
places and at first astronomers said oh
yeah
it's probably just like the objects we
had in our solar system all the rocks
that we have seen before
we've seen comets and asteroids
so a a comet is a rock that is covered
with ice
water ice so when it gets close to the
sun
the surface gets warmed up and the ice
turns into vapor
[Music]
gas and you see this beautiful cometary
tail
behind it that's what a comet is an
asteroid is just rock without much ice
on it
actually the first person to explain
what comets are
was at harvard the university that i am
affiliated with
and the story goes that i mean it was
fred whipple that
he went to harvard square and saw all
the slush
during the winter day you know and came
up with the idea that it's just
icy rock or rc i see rocks or you know
rocky ice uh and that's what a
comet is and the comets come to us from
the periphery of the solar system
and you know astronomers said okay other
stars may have them as well
and you know since they are loosely
bound if they are
in the periphery they can be easily
ripped apart from their host star
and some of them will fly in our
direction we will see them so
they said o muamma is probably a comet
the only problem is there wasn't any
cometary tale
so you look for a duck but it doesn't
look like a duck
you know so then the question is what is
it and so people say okay it's
just a rock without any ice on it
then the problem was that it exhibited
an extra push
away from the sun and usually you get it
from
the rocket effect that when when you
make the cometary tail
uh it pushes the object in the opposite
direction just like a jet plane
a jet plane works by throwing gas out
and that's pushing you forward so a
comet
has an extra push when it evaporates
but there was no commentary there so why
did it show an extra push that was the
key question
in my mind at which point i started
thinking maybe it's not a comet
and not an asteroid something else you
know and
the other strange thing about it it it
changes its
brightness by a factor of 10 or more
and the brightness of the object the
light that we see is simply reflected
sunlight
so just think about it think about a
piece of paper
razor thin piece of paper tumbling in
the wind
and changing the area that we can see
the projected area of that piece of
paper by a factor of 10
as we look at it that's exactly what we
inferred from this object spinning
around every eight hours but
changing its brightness by a factor of
10 meaning that the area projected on
the sky
that we see that reflects sunlight
changed by a factor of 10 so that means
it has an extreme geometry
most likely flat if you try to interpret
the
light that it reflected over as it was
tumbling around and so a flat object
about the size of a football field that
has an
extra push if it were a comet it needed
to lose about a tenth of its
weight so a lot of evaporation you can't
just say oh it's a little bit of
evaporation and
therefore that's why we don't see it it
should have lost a tenth of
its weight you know if we go on a diet
and lose a tenth of our weight that's
that's a big chunk of of mass right
so this object didn't lose that because
we didn't see it and the speed of space
telescope looked very deeply
behind it to see if there are any traces
of dust or gas didn't see anything
so then you know just like sherlock
holmes i was
trying to think together with a
postdoc of mine uh shmuel bialy what
could explain
it and the only thing that came to mind
is reflecting sunlight
so the object itself is being pushed by
the sunlight
reflecting off its surface and you know
that would agree with everything we know
about the object
but in order for it to work the object
needs to be very thin
like a sail you know the sail on a boat
uh so a sail is pushed by a wind
uh but you can also push an object a
thin object
by light and that is called the light
sail
and we're actually using this technology
now developing it
for space exploration the big advantage
is you don't need to carry the fuel
with the spacecraft you just reflect
light off it and it's being pushed
now a science fiction movie that did
something like that i think it was
called sunlight
quite possibly i should mention an
anecdote in september just a few months
ago in september 2020
there was another object that showed an
extra push no commentary tail
and then astronomers so astronomers gave
it a name 2020
so okay september 2020 and then
they uh extrapolated back in time and
found that it
came from earth actually and then they
looked at the history books and show
and and so that indeed there was a
rocket booster
from a lunar lander that was kicked into
space
and this is the object now why did it
show this push because it's a hollow
it's a very thin
structure so here is an example where
we can tell it's artificial and we know
that we made it
but umuamua could not have been made by
us because it was passing near us just
for a few months
very quickly faster than any rocket that
we can launch
that's why we couldn't really chase it
when it was receding away from us and it
came from outside the solar system
so you know i just do one plus one equal
to i say okay
it looks very peculiar maybe
it belongs to another civilization i
just put it in a scientific paper
i didn't think you know we didn't have
any press release then it went
viral the public got extremely
interested and the thing that really
surprised me is that my colleagues were
pushing back they were very upset that
this possibility was even mentioned
you know we had a seminar a lecture
about this object
at harvard and if a colleague of mine
after the lecture said this object is
really weird
i wish it never existed now to me
you know that i was really appointed by
this how can you say something like that
you should you should be happy about
whatever nature gives you
you know you learn something new if if
something doesn't look right
it actually teaches us oh it's a
learning experience we learned that
we have to revise the way we think about
reality you know
that's a good thing that's not a bad you
shouldn't always be in your comfort zone
and think that the future will be the
same as the past
so i actually see it as a blessing you
know
i can't imagine why anybody would be
upset that it exists
like i wish it didn't exist that's kind
of hilarious because it takes you away
from your comfort zone
you know i know but it's if you're
studying the heavens
you're studying the cosmos what is the
ultimate thing that you could find
another civilization or
a piece of something well another
civilization that's exactly my point but
if you go back in time let me give you
okay two examples
uh galileo galilei said i think
the earth moves around the sun but at
the time
philosophers knew for sure that the sun
moves around the earth you see it moving
in the sky it was consistent with their
religious beliefs everything
so they said we don't want to look
through your telescope
to change our view we will put you in
house arrest
now what did they achieve by that and by
the way i'm in house arrest but it's
because of the pandemic not because
so what did they achieve by that they
maintained their ignorance
and the earth continued to move around
the sun you know reality is the one
thing that never goes away
irrespective whether you ignore it you
can ignore it now there is another
example there is a
student a student at harvard that as a
result of my book
on this subject that is about to come
out in in a week or so
she she was inspired to do her phd
by you know on the theme of my book so
she invited me to a thesis exam just a
couple of months ago
and one of the examiners a professor
asked her
do you know why giordano bruno
an italian guy was burned at the stake
and she said well he was an obnoxious
guy he irritated a lot of people which
is true
you know he was an abnormal but the
professor corrected her and said
no it was because he said that other
stars
are just like the sun you know there are
stars like the sun
and they have planets like the earth
around them
and there may be life on those planets
and that was offensive to the church
because if there is life there
and it had sinned you know
then christ should have visited those
planets to save them
to save the life life forms and you know
you need
multi copies of christ to
to visit those planets and that was
unacceptable so they burned the guy
so you see that you know throughout
history
people are not really open-minded about
the sky
the heavens as you said catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience